un peu de sport avec cette incroyable
performance des footballeuses U13 de
trap elles sont revenu hier de Bastia
avec le titre de la made et whisly vous
le voyez le trophée de cette compétition
est avec nous en plateau le plus grand
tournoi de football on le rappelle
amateur en France en cette madewi League
les Yvelinois se sont imposés en finale
face à l'Olympique de Marseille au terme
d'une séance de tir au but il y avait eu
0 à 0 à l'issue du temps réglementaire
et cette finale s'est déroulée au stade
Armand Cesari de Bastia on va revenir
sur cette grosse performance avec nos
invités je les ai tout à l'heure il y a
Rodrigue mbezi le coach des U13 féminine
de trappes et vous avez été rejoint par
la gardienne Akima hierjalène bonsoir
également par la capitaine Nina à midi
bonsoir de cette équipe U13 féminine on
va commencer avec vous d'ailleurs Lina
en tant que capitaine de l'équipe là ça
y est on est deux jours après cette
victoire dans cette madewy's League vous
avez d'ailleurs inscrit le tir au but de
la victoire il me semble si je dis pas
de bêtises comment vous sentez après
cette victoire cette
compétitions je me sentais du bonheur et
c'était vraiment quelque chose de
remporter la main de whislik on sait pas
déplacé pour rien et on a gagné contre
une grande équipe quand même l'Olympique
de Marseille et toute l'équipe a fait le
taf et vraiment je remercie on a fait
une très grande saison et le taf a plié
hier ou avant-hier avec le trophée de la
modélisme et racontez-moi l'émotion que
vous avez ressenti au moment où vous
avez inscrit ce tir au but victorieux
mais pour moi c'était de la joie et je
suis parti direct voir nos supporters
qui nous ont supporté tout le tournoi
et il y a aussi l'héroïne de cette
finale on peut la présenter comme ça
avec nous en plateau Hakima à regarder
puisque vous avez arrêté de penalty je
pense qu'on les a déjà vu mais on va les
revoir voilà on voit les images de cette
finale peut-être l'un de vos
penaltyrtilles effectivement voilà l'un
des penaltys stoppé je disais vous en
avez stoppé même deux au cours de cette
séance mais quel qu'est-ce que vous
retenez de cette victoire quel regard
vous portez sur sur votre performance
sur la performance aussi de vos
coéquipiers
vous êtes fier vous êtes fier de ce que
vous avez accompli oui je suis très très
fière de d'avoir arrêté les deux buts au
turbute
ça Rodrigue de stopper deux tirs au but
dans une finale ça fait basculer le
match là il y a eu 00 réglementaire une
gardienne de but qui arrête deux tirs au
but c'est c'est déterminant pas pour
tout vous dire bah en fait sur ce type
de rencontre on est obligé de calcul de
jouer avec ses forces et ses faiblesses
donc là je vais fasse une équipe qui
était très très forte et techniquement
donc le plan qui avait été choisi pour
la rencontre c'était bah de gestion de
la patience en tout cas moi je tiens à
remercier mes filles parce qu'elles ont
fait preuve de détermination c'est je
les attendais un certain niveau
sincèrement mais pas ce niveau de
détermination là c'est quoi l'ambiance
avant la finale c'était confiantes où il
y avait un petit peu d'appréhension
avant d'affronter l'OM il y a peut-être
d'ailleurs des supportrices de l'OM au
sein de votre équipe c'est possible
aussi oui tout à fait mais je pense
qu'on a fait attraction alors là je
pense que chacun défendait ses couleurs
et en fait la tendance avant la
rencontre c'est que en fait dans ma dans
mon mode de management tu as été bah je
pense
super efficace parce qu'en fait on a eu
le temps de préparer la rencontre c'est
pas comme le samedi matin on arrive à 1h
du coup d'envoi on bricole un peu là on
a eu quand même quasiment 24 heures pour
préparer à la rencontre donc on était
assez détendu on a appelé les parents
pour aller chercher de la confiance de
la motivation et des champs payés et
alors au final qui a été commenté le
commentateur a parlé alors il a utilisé
un terme force celui de braquage réalisé
par trappes vous êtes d'accord avec ça
ou c'est quand même un peu fort comme
mot le braquage il y avait quand même il
y avait une place en finale donc il y a
pas eu de braquage avant quand même non
c'est que le parcours était maîtrisé dès
le départ on savait que dans cette
compétition qu'on était venu chercher
quelque chose parce qu'en fait j'ai une
petite histoire qui est super marrante
c'est que à la madibus Cup donc qui est
l'étape qualificative Lina qui
d'habitude fait pas attention aux
règlements tout ça c'est concentré sur
le règlement et a attendu dire qu'en
fait que la finaliste les finalistes a
des participants à la donc elle m'avait
promis d'y aller donc au début j'étais
un peu sceptique et au final ils sont
allés sauf qu'on a rencontré une
difficulté on a perdu la finale donc moi
je pensais que les tickets suffisait ça
a pas suffi donc à ce sont consoler
c'est chez les larmes brebis au boulot
et on a gagné à madagas League grâce à
ce retour d'expense qui est super
magnifique Nicolas tu parlais de taf du
travail du coup fait durant toute la
saison c'est quoi concrètement
on a bossé on a travaillé pour y arriver
aujourd'hui et on a fait le taf on s'est
mis à travailler on a dit c'est pas
grave on a perdu quelque chose mais on
est parti jusqu'au bout et on a réussi à
gagner la prochaine étape
mais c'est la vie des défaites et de
repartir de pouvoir repartir petite
question piège comment tu qualifies le
coachri Rodrigue
le cosmique c'est un bon coach il nous
donne
les bons choix les bons postes il sait
il sait comment faire il sait son taf et
ça a payé avec un bon coach alors c'est
une victoire qui a fait beaucoup de
Trappes on va voir les images hier de
votre retour dans la vie c'était au
niveau du stade Gilbert Champsec avec
quoi 150 personnes vous me disiez tout à
l'heure audrigue qui était venu pour
vous pour vous accueillir
Akima peut-être qu'est-ce que ça vous a
fait de voir autant de personnes
l'avenir vous acclamer ça monte quand
même que vous avez réalisé une grosse
performance à Bastia
quand j'avais vu qu'il y avait beaucoup
de gens ils étaient très fiers parce que
j'ai jamais enfin jamais célébrer un
truc si enfin une victoire comme ça
c'est un premier souvenir de cette
ampleur pour vous
ce que vous avez ressenti en voyant on
va toutes ces personnes heureuses et
réunies pour vous à votre arrivée à
trappe mais j'ai vu que dans la section
féminine il y avait beaucoup de
personnes qui nous supportaient il y
avait beaucoup de personnes derrière
nous et on a dû qu'on allait gagner ça
pour le club pour la section féminine
pour ceux qui nous supportent derrière
nous et voilà
une question parce que le sport c'est
alors oui il y a la qualité physique
mais c'est aussi du mental c'est quoi
l'état d'esprit entre vous les filles
est-ce que vous êtes amis vous voyez
aussi à l'extérieur du sport après les
entraînements avant les entraînements
est-ce que vous vous sortez peut-être
vous voyez à l'école peut-être et puis
les mêmes questions pour toi Rodrigue
est-ce que avant tout c'est une bande de
copines qui se sont engagées les jours
au football ensemble et c'est peut-être
ça qui a fait la différence sur le
tournoi
en fait par rapport à cette session
féminine a toujours été constituée comme
ça en fait c'est qu'on a toujours fait
en sorte de d'intégrer des filles pour
créer des collectifs donc on a la chance
qu'on a c'est que burn on a le modèle
chez les garçons on va pas se mentir
contre duplique chez les filles c'est
vrai que nous on a une manière très
particulière de voir le football c'est
que on part du principe que on peut
perdre des matchs ça arrive mais à
partir du moment où l'adversaire est
plus fort que nous j'accepte ma défaite
mais si c'est pas le cas on lâche rien
jusqu'au bout
vous en avez parlé un petit peu tout à
l'heure Rodrigue pour arriver jusqu'à
cette finale remportée face à
l'Olympique de Marseille il y a eu
d'abord le parcours régional et quel
était le parcours lors de la finale du
coup quelle équipe vous avez pu
affronter donc on a affronter pour le
premier match nos amis de
Rueil-Malmaison donc pareil le permis
francilien donc on est mené un zéro à
quelques secondes de la fin on égaise
donc on fait un partout de deuxième
match contre nos amis de croissante par
une équipe super accrocheuse qui nous
avait vu jouer le premier match donc à
essayer mes faiblesses mais bon on fait
0-0 et en fait c'est au cours de la 2e
journée on s'est révélé on commence par
une victoire 3-0 contre le club de
bussiglia le club corse et on termine
sur une victoire 3 euros contre le
Sporting Club de Bastia et puis pour
assurer la place de classement donc on
fait 00 contre l'Olympique de Marseille
ça va l'ambiance face au club corse
c'était pas trop chaud face aux équipes
corses qui étaient à domicile il y avait
les supporters qui supportaient pour eux
qu'ils étaient pour eux il y en a eu
beaucoup mais on a on a réussi à garder
la pression on a joué comme on savait
jouer et les supporters pour nous
c'était rien du tout ça faisait pas de
bruit on était concentré dans notre
match et c'était pour la qualification
finalement et du coup il y a eu cette
victoire on le rappelle en finale face à
l'Olympique de Marseille vous l'avez vu
vécu comment le tournoi finalement vous
étiez un peu dans la peau de
professionnels on peut le dire dans ce
tournoi Hakima oui
et le trophée était remis par Djibril
Cissé vous le connaissiez Djibril Cissé
avant de faire le tournoi
français qui a joué notamment Auxerre il
a été format Auxerre mais pas que
beaucoup de beaucoup de clubs dans sa
carrière ça c'était aussi un honneur
Rodrigue de pouvoir
avoir le trophée qui est remis par
Djibril 6 au-delà du Trophée ce qui est
extraordinaire pour moi en tant que
coach c'est que j'ai reçu un message la
veille de la finale on me demandant ma
compo des fils a très bien que mes
compos sont ultra secrètes voire
confidentiel donc j'ai joué le jeu et ça
aussi la différence parce qu'en fait en
terme de en termes de prestige c'est
magnifique ce que le match a été
commenté par
saberge de TF1 de TF1 tout à fait ça a
été un honneur aussi de le rencontrer
c'est en fait je remercie Franck le
président de madewi qui est amis des
équipes dans des conditions juste
exceptionnelles pour des amateurs c'est
juste incroyable donc on le remerciera
jamais assez pour cet événement la suite
des événements pour votre équipe donc on
prépare la fête du samedi 17 juin donc
on organise notre premier tournoi
féminin en catégorie U11 et U13 donc on
espère que tout le monde viendra
nombreux pour saluer la performance des
filles parce que attrape notre section
féminine est très très importante et
puis on présentera de trophée à nos amis
supporters en tout cas merci d'être venu
avec ce trophée en plateau voilà je le
remonte de cette madewi League remporté
par les U13 féminines de l'Étoile
Sportive de trappe une victoire en
disait en finale à l'issue de la séance
de tir au but face à l'Olympique de
Marseille bravo à Hakima bravolina bravo
Rodrigue pour cette énorme performance
bravo bien sûr à toutes les joueuses de
l'Étoile Sportive de trap et surtout
merci d'être venu en parlant plateau
vous êtes revenu tout juste hier de
cette grosse performance et de ce gros
tournoi je pense qu'il va rester
longtemps dans votre mémoire merci
d'être venu débriefer tout ça avec nous
en plateau